the the Californian Silicon Valley Bank
got into trouble Midway through last
week
um and the problem was that depositors
got increasingly worried about the
safety of their money in the bank that
caused a classic Bank Run one of the
most dramatic ever in history in fact
um we have a UK part of the Silicon
Valley Bank here in the UK it's actually
separate it's a subsidiary here in the
UK
um it's management tried to sort of
reassure customers here that things were
fine but people were worried that what
was going on over in the U.S might have
contagion here in the UK so that's led
to a situation where the bank of England
has said that it may need to step in and
resolve the UK part but this weekend
there could potentially be an option for
another big bank here in the UK to take
over the British part of Silicon Valley
Bank
just give us an idea of how big this
bank is because most people wouldn't
even have heard of it
that's right lots and lots of people
won't have heard of it but actually it
plays a really big part in the tech
sector both in the US and in the UK and
indeed in other countries too it's got
40 Years of History real expertise and
providing banking services for Tech
businesses Life Sciences businesses and
certainly here in Britain that's the
case and a group of those firms have
written to the government to say it's
really important that this bank doesn't
go down and that our own Investments
deposits in the bank don't go down too
so the chance to Jeremy Hunt has said
they're looking at it very closely and
we'll see what happens I think the
trouble is that for lots of people in
the in the wider World they might think
well hang on a second
um are we actually going to see taxpayer
money being put at risk here to save
sort of tech businesses Life Sciences
businesses when perhaps their own
shareholders their own owners maybe
um called upon to step forward
Mr Hunt has said that he was working
with both the Prime Minister and the
governor of Bank of England
to avoid or minimize damage resulting
from the chaos engulfing this um this
bank I mean do you think they'll be able
to do that
there's this now this 24-hour deadline
but can they actually minimize the
damage
there are lots of options available to
them
um I imagine they might quite like it if
a big bag High Street Bank would step
forward and take over Silicon Valley
bank and then sort of immediately
overnight take on its its
responsibilities and liabilities if that
doesn't happen then the government has a
few options I think most likely what
they'll try to do is provide some sort
of short-term funding so that when Tech
firms which use Silicon Valley Bank open
on Monday there's some sort of money
there for them to keep paying their
staff basically so it's a sort of
short-term lending liquidity scheme that
the government might well look at to try
and keep all these firms operational and
not you know what they want to avoid of
potentially tens of thousands of sort of
job losses and failures across UK Tech
so when do you think we'll know in the
next 24 hours I guess
yeah I think they'll be desperately Keen
to have something if they possibly can
do
um ready to go before the Stock Market
opens tomorrow morning I think Jeremy
Hunters talked about in the next few
days but they'll be very very aware of
of the potential benefit of getting it
ready before the markets open
going back to the the um the original
Bank in the U.S didn't its president a
couple of years ago press Congress to
reduce scrutiny of the bank and they
agreed
I've really no idea if its president did
request that
um I think I think the trouble is that
um Silicon Valley bank is in the US is a
better known bank and certainly very
respected and has lots of expertise in
its area but actually what it's done is
mismanaged its assets and liabilities it
invested in lots and lots of longer term
bonds and then it was caught out by
interest rate Rises which meant the
value of those bonds fell it's by no
mean means alone in having done that but
the problem was that people started to
lose confidence in it and started to
yank out their deposits Silicon Valley
Bank had to sell off those bonds and
it's kind of created this vicious circle
that we've now seen I think one of the
things that really worried people at the
end of last week was whether there would
be contagion of this problem into other
Banks and certainly a lot of other bank
share prices were hit
um I think there'll be lots of people
out there who will be very keen need to
point out that actually Silicon Valley
Banks problems were quite specific in
terms of the concentration of its
challenges and problems not least the
fact that it's in a sector where it's
it's a very sort of uh narrow sector
that operates in that in that in itself
caused some problems the fact that there
were there were changes in the dynamic
of the VC market so I think people will
be very keen to try and be cautious and
if indeed there are other wider problems
then they will need to be addressed but
I think just sort of a general sense of
panic is I'm already unwarranted